nous sommes une équipe d'Antenne 2 et on
réalise le premier magazine de charme et
de séduction de la télévision française
et on voudrait vous demander si vous
accepteriez pour la télévision de nous
montrer un petit peu quelque chose de
vous que vous ne montrez pas d'habitude
dans la rue
oui votre nombril par exemple dans la
rue vous voule dire
voilà montrer mes FS oui par exemple
voilà voilà voilà c'est très bien on n
pas très très bien vu enfin ça fait rien
il fait tropis
rum un seul un
seul ça ira
là plus voil c'est très très bien
voil
Jez plaisir vous allez voir ça vaê trs
très
joli
vous a montré l'aile je vous montre la
cuisse ah très bien
voilà nous avons les deux le haut et le
[Musique]
bas
plus ça va comme
çaz quelque
chose par exemple sera
bienès mign
voilcep moner une partie de votre corps
que vous cachez habituellement euh
oui
voilà